[Background voices]
RD THULASIRAJ >> Hi, YouTube. This is Thulasiraj
representing Aravind Eye Care system in Moderai,
south India. Ah, this is wholly sure of ethics-ah-whether
the business community should adopt some of
the ethics, at least as stated in the health
care community as for the doctors and others.
Ah-my personal opinion is-ah-yes, it should.
Ah-I think we also need to make it more a
point of practice rather than just being just
a-this oath being taken. But the core of it
is how do you create the __________ paradigm.
More vote for your customer and-ah-in the
case of health care, for the patient and the
doctor. In the case of business, the-within
the business and the customer. How do we engage
in a process that is non-exploitative and
that truly adds value both to the customer
and to the business in a way that it mutually
synergizes. And to me this should form the
core foundation for-um-the development of
such an ethics framework. I just want-ah-I
wouldn't be able to get into details of spelling
it out, I think that is a much larger debate.
But I think-I strongly feel creating this
_____________ as a paradigm or the foundation
is-is the way to go.